it's not french is a pretty easy one to
cover
romanian
um okay so someone gave me a language
but uh let me type
wow that's interesting
hello danielle
hello how's it going
good that's good
i gotta ask but is mutty still around
good question yeah it's a really good
question he is in berlin
since the second side we have i haven't
heard of him
yeah with the job and i think yeah
he got busy but i think we'll soon hear
from him
ah surely not sure that's like a funny
so
multi is always a funny thing because in
dutch multi
is kind of like buddy
[Laughter]
so i used to tell like the pie data like
amsterdam people back and they're like
no i'm going to go to musi or your buddy
yeah
party berlin but not like that the other
way
his name is it was always kind of fun
follow the gimmick there
i think i will stop uh
adding people to the zoom everyone else
can just
watch it on youtube i guess and ask
questions there
any objections
yeah i'll put it on meetup also the
streaming link
or it's already done
can someone already pass it i cannot i'm
doing it
so let's see
okay and 5.7
i think we can
can start let me share the
press the record button
yes okay so welcome everyone
uh welcome to this uh pi data berlin uh
february edition 2021 uh one more time
online uh so we have two talks uh
today uh but first i would like to
remind you
uh about pi data so we
are part of nam focus
and as part of focus we have a code of
conduct
uh the short version being uh be nice do
not
be respectful of the others um
and everything will be fine
and without further notice let's go to
the
first talk by vincent
so we will talk about his work as raza
and about chatbots
and uh please if you have any questions
uh do not hesitate
to write it in the chat or if you're on
the youtube you can also put it in the
chat there
and we'll forward it to the speaker
cool let me just make sure i've got my
chat window open here as well so it
looks good
uh also to the crowd like we can see me
doodle i hope right this is something
that we can all see
grand grand canyon brand so hi everyone
my name is vincent i won't be talking
about chatbots too much today
like i'll talk about all sorts of
byproducts that we've
got now but i won't be talking too much
about chatbots themselves
first of all hello my name is vincent
i'm a research advocate at braza
so a big part of what i do is
i make some youtube videos explain like
some of the algorithms that we make
and the reason that i uh you know do
this
is because it's my job to sort of
interface on one end with our research
team and we're doing
you know kind of advanced numerical
tricks to make chatbots work so there's
like complicated stuff here
i need to interface with developers as
well and the main thing that i'm trying
to do is make sure that
some of the things that our research
team does is
you know accessible to my lovely group
of community developers here
but also the other way around that if
cool things are happening
in you know the community that the
research team is also kind of aware of
that and
this is the ground that i'm trying to
cover i do a little bit of research but
i'm also a little bit more focused
toward the developer advocacy so to say
particular um you can kind of pick the
problem you work on at raza
but in particular i'm very interested in
doing everything uh
possible to me for non-english use cases
i think there's a lot of cool papers a
lot of really cool work
on english natural language processing
but the world is much bigger right it's
not just
english we need multiple languages
supported
and my particular realm of interest is
this non-english bit
so some of the things i do with raza is
i open source a couple of tools that are
useful to explore this
um i also host some browser-compatible
tools for
non-english developers but the
interesting thing that happened
last year which i didn't really
anticipate is that
you know besides me being vincent the
guy who works at raza and the person
who's a you know research advocate
um i'm also like
an open source kind of person i have
lots of hobby projects and lots of
projects that i maintain
and also lots of projects that i
contribute to um
i you know i fair learn as a project
i've spent some effort on
um there's some of these loose so i
could learn compatible packages that i
maintain
and i like to think of myself as someone
who's actively working for raza
but while i work for raza i also have my
own independent work that i'm doing on
the side
um keep your eyes peeled for a tool
that's going to come out next week by
the way
but if i'm going to talk about anything
today what i would really like to talk
about
is how this kind of weird happy open
source
accident happened um because what
happened a couple of months ago is i was
working on my own thing
while working on the raza thing and it
turned out that these two completely
different
tracks of work we're able to merge in a
very lovely way and
the reason why i think i want to maybe
focus in on that because it's because it
also gives us a observation
on maybe this new mindset that we might
be able to do in research which i
to me at least was kind of a neat
observation
um having said all of this
um what i'm going to do now and for the
rest of the talk
is live demoing so i'm going to try to
explain what i mean by everything i've
just said
so oh shortcuts shortcuts shortcuts
there we go um
i'm hoping this is can people read this
this is like good size
font wise cool
i think it was a lot about five months
ago i started this open source project
called
human learn and it's kind of like
psyched learn but the idea is instead of
algorithms trying to find patterns
it'd be kind of nice if we had a way to
have humans come up with decent rules
instead i think there's a lot of really
good domain knowledge and i would like
to have domain knowledge be more psyched
learn compatible um
kind of you know a little bit of a
project that goes against the hype
but the main idea i really want to do is
i want to make it easier for people to
write rules
they can take in data and produce labels
because i think there's a lot of
human intelligence natural intelligence
that we can do here instead of just
always focusing on the artificial kind
and there's a bunch of features in this
library that is really really lovely
but here's my favorite one
let's say that this is a data set that
you're interested in classifying right
so
um you've got your red dots you've got
your green dots you've got your blue
dots we've got an enterprise use case we
want to you know the classification
thing that's the thing we're interested
in
then what you could do is you could say
well let's do this complicated algorithm
thing and that's this geometric trick
that's going to separate all these
classes
but i hope that you recognize just from
you know looking at this particular data
set
you don't need any like tensorflow or
anything like that here just kind of
want to
draw a circle around the class and just
say you know if if a new point falls
within this shape
then i'll just call that red so one of
the main features that this library
allows you to do is it allows you to do
exactly this
you can just draw a shape oh i need to
use the actual mouse for this
my bad sounds not great for everything
but what this library basically allows
you to do is you can just sort of draw a
shape
and say okay that's the red class
here's the blue one here's the green one
and if we ever get like a new data point
in
then we can kind of do this point in
poly algorithm thing where
you know if a point falls here it's
probably green and if there's a point
over here well it's probably an outlier
like we can do
very simple stuff like this really if
you think about it
the data's already there
and i could do this on multiple axes
right so i
uh i can do this with two dimensions but
i can do this with n dimensions but just
making more of these separate charts and
you can keep drawing
but what i thought was pretty neat is
just sort of the whole design aspect of
this
um what i just did is i all the data
that i just drew is inside of this
variable over here
and i'm putting that inside of this
interactive classifier which is
basically saying take what i drew over
here
and turn it into something that psyched
learn can handle that you can also grid
search over if you really wanted to
and just as a proof of concept you can
see that you know what i just drew are
also the predictions that we're making
here but
the main thing that i liked about this
view is just the whole point of
when you're exploring a data set the
first time
you don't want to do the xg boosting you
actually want to sort of actually go and
explore a data set
and by doing this trick first if only as
a benchmark
you have this nice little aspect that
you're forced to actually look at your
data and think about it
and that was kind of the point i wanted
to make with this library just a sort of
idea of you know you don't always need
complex algorithms
you can also maybe get some domain
knowledge in and have like a benchmark
model based on that so if it works
pretty well
you know then maybe you don't need
tensorflow that was sort of the vantage
point that i had
now what i'm showing you here this is
something i made on my own it's just
something i figured would be a cool
thing to do
and the nice thing about you know living
on github sometimes is that people can
collaborate and
there's some really interesting products
out there i'm not doing anything super
serious with this but i
but i have heard people like use this in
production which is pretty neat but this
is something i was doing
on my own end
while i was doing this though i started
i also started working
at raza and at raza we noticed that we
kind of had this one
sort of interesting issue and that was
that
on one end we wanted to make sure that
people who were using raza
kind of understood word embeddings and
also what's in them
and on the other side we also figured
well it'd be kind of nice if we had this
really
like just useful quick api that allows
us to just evaluate a bunch
of embeddings real quick we kind of need
this library that tells us what lies in
word embeddings
and that's how the ball got rolling on
this project that's hosted on braza
it's independent of raza you can just
download it independently
but the idea of this package is called
what lies because we want to use it to
figure out what
lies in word embeddings
the way it works is you can say well
there's a back end
in this case i'm saying well let's take
some byte pair embeddings those are
a particular kind of word embedding
that's robust against spelling mistakes
and then i have this language object and
what i can do is i can
kind of like panda style just say look
if this is a dictionary of source of all
sorts of word embeddings
i just want to put all of my words in
there and then get sort of a data frame
out that represents like a collection of
vectors
like names with arrays so to say
so one thing that that just for uh
demonstration purposes if i take that
bypair language
and i give it the word man and then i
get this embedding object and inside of
that
is this uh this vector so to say so this
is just a retrieval method to get like
vectors out
but the cool thing about having that in
like a data frame kind of
setting instead is that you can more
easily add plotting
functionality on top of that so one
thing i can do is i can say you could
just plot
the similarity
between all the words that are in here
let's use cosine distance for that
uh oh metric
oh it's kind of nice and funny and
interesting and cool that you can sort
of see well there's a couple of word
clusters
uh happening inside of here and this
gives us like a very convenient way to
maybe explore that because
i can also tweak the settings here a bit
so i can say well i would like to have
like a larger vocabulary size or a
smaller one there's all sorts of
settings that i can tweak here
but i have this nifty little plotting
functionality that's available to me
now what's nice about this is that byte
pair embeddings are just one kind of
embedding
but there's also other types of
embeddings you can make embeddings based
off of psychic learn you can make
a tf idf vector embedding you can get
embeddings from hugging face you can get
them from tensorflow
but what lies tries to do is what lies
basically says well we make sure that
you just have to talk to like
one single api and one single api only
and we do our best to make sure that we
cover as much ground as far as support
goes
so that means that we actually have a
couple of back ends that we support out
of the box
so jensen we do uh some of this i could
learn tricks we do
fast text sentence birth hugging face
spacey tensorflow hub like these are all
natively supported so if you have any
embedding
from those uh then you can just use our
library to do visual stuff
basically but it's not just visual stuff
that we do
because all of our language embeddings
are also scikit-learn compatible
so um i'm assuming i'm talking to a
crowd who's done psychic learn before
and so if you have like your data set in
this xy format and you would like to
make a prediction
then you can use any language model that
this library provides
and it will behave like a transformer
like a standard scalar so let's say
all of these language models that you
have here are models where text goes
in on one side of the the component
let's just draw that out
and on the other side you get basically
a vector
that belongs to that text and it doesn't
matter if using hugging face you can
always use this api
so if you just want to do some quick
benchmarks on whatever language you're
interested in
you can totally do that here
and there's one thing that's actually
particularly cool about this bi-pair
language setting because
the byte pair embeddings itself we can
kind of just uh maybe just show you the
website real quick
bpm it's a it's a project that
there's a couple of numeric tricks that
are happening inside of this library too
that are really awesome but
the main thing that's really epic about
this project in particular
is that it supports um
275 languages so
even if you're working in non-english
odds are that there is a pre-trained
language embedding
for you that you can go ahead and play
with um
so just to give a quick demo what i'm
just gonna go ahead and do
is just type in the word embedding
languages that people were asking for in
chat so i think romanian was one of them
but romanian is definitely supported
so what i can do is i can sort of take
this language code over here and just
um put that inside of so i could learn
and sort of play around with it
um this is the only change you need to
do to have a language embedding for
romanian
and when you run this uh the first time
it will sort of download all of these
things
but once it's done downloading you're
good to go
so just as a demo right because i think
it'd be kind of cool to show
um what i've got here is greek so just
some greek words and
i took the words that i had before to
google translate
and you can see that you know we we get
the same similarity chart out which is
definitely uh kind of nice
um and this is nice because you can also
make the comparison of hey are
the same kind of word embedding trained
on english wikipedia
do the embeddings represent something
differently than if i do that for
turkish or whatever other language
but i also support languages like
[Music]
telugu indirectly however if you use
those languages you get into this
interesting other dimension of support
for language um
because i support like the the vectors
just come out that's completely fine but
the issue with some languages in
matplotlib
is that matplotlib cannot always handle
the characters
which is also the sort of small little
bummer
um so luckily one thing that we can do
nowadays on the web is we could say well
instead of relying on matplotlib it
would be nice if we can have like a
rendering engine that's kind of
guaranteed to be able to handle most
language type sets so what we also
offer are
visualizations that are based on the oh
whoops we need to rerun that sorry
i thought i ran this
there we go but what we can do
is we can say well i'm interested in
making this plot but
i want to plot it directly on a web
interface
so that's what you see here because you
know a browser is actually meant to be
able to render just about anything
you'll find that there's a lot better
language support if you just have an
interactive visualization that can just
you know draw on the canvas so say
so one of the things that we also
support is we also support this idea of
you know take the word embeddings this
is a data frame of embedding so to say
and we can say well let's transform that
by doing a principle components analysis
and let's then make these alter charts
so you can have like
you know these interactive
visualizations on the pca dimensions
zoom out once more so you can kind of
see it
and what's kind of cool here is you know
you can kind of explore where some of
the clusters are and if you're working
in the multi-language setting
you would really like to confirm that
certain clusters that you expect are
actually in here
before you put it into a classifier
so you know this i i figured this is
pretty useful this is pretty interesting
right like we have psyched learn
compatibility we have
hugging face and all these language
back-ends that's pretty cool
but here's where the happy accident
happened um
i have these views right so i can
definitely see like hey there's a
cluster over here
but at the same time i was also looking
at this chart and sort of going
you know what's really nice about this
is that i can just draw a circle around
like a couple of points
and sort of assign a label to that using
this trick that i've got here
inside of human learn that idea is
pretty nice
and if i now start looking at what i've
got here and
you know what is actually going to be
useful to like some of my rasa
end users who i'm trying to help with no
english
well then i might need to take a step
back and wonder
maybe we shouldn't use these embeddings
just for classification maybe that's not
necessarily the big problem
you see a lot of these embeddings in the
end they're trained on something like
wikipedia
and if you think about what wikipedia
represents that's you know
amazing spelling super formal probably
about something in history
but if you think about how language is
used online like in a more
you know assistant setting it'll be like
full of spelling errors super informal
and something that's happening right now
as opposed to something that happened
a long time ago so maybe
you know these embeddings are like
pretty interesting and all but
maybe it's not just for making
classifications that they're interesting
maybe instead we should use them for
labeling
because you notice that there is this
clustering happening here right
and you can imagine that if you're
starting out with a new assistant in a
non-english setting
the probably the first problem that you
have isn't do i have embeddings
but it's do i have appropriate training
data in the first place
if you're working on an assistant and
let's say you're a business then the
likely scenario is that you do have
let's say some social media data
of like customers asking frequently
asked questions or like
you know you have these logs of
conversations that you already had
and it might be a better idea to wonder
like can we take that data
and maybe more quickly label that real
quick to get like a gold label standard
going as quickly as possible
as opposed to like only taking a few
data sets with like a
few labels and using word embeddings to
optimize uh
there so that got me thinking like hey
maybe i need to combine the human learn
idea with this what lies thing that got
going
um so
that's what i've done here
now i'm about to show you a demo but
just to give you an impression of what's
happening right
the way this this is a notebook and it's
kind of a project on its own that's open
source everyone can download it
but the way this works is i assume that
you have text that we would like to
label
i then pass that through a language
model and that can be anything it can be
something based on tensorflow hugging
face or whatever
i then end up with a embedding of sorts
and what i can then do is a
dimensionality reduction technique
that lures the clusters out to then give
me a two dimensional view
and then probably what i can do is in
this two-dimensional view
i can do the trick where i do the
selection and maybe this is a very
convenient way for me to do like bulk
labeling i won't be getting gold labels
but i will be getting like maybe bronze
or silver ones
and the idea here isn't so much that i
get like the best labels right away
but it is the idea that i am able to
plow through lots of data relatively
quickly
so what i've got here is a training file
from a razerbot
um i've passed that through the
universal sentence encoder
and that went through umap and what you
end up with is plotted here
and what i'm able to do is just make a
selection of a particular cluster
and i can say well let's let's show the
examples of that cluster and
one of the like really convenient things
these days as jupiter labs
these widgets just kind of work so you
can just make your own user interface
happen real quick here
and you know there's actually like a
whole bunch of points here i can
actually
probably just maybe uh zoom in just a
little bit here
but there's like a lot of points over on
this end
so instead of like
assuming that these are all the rows i
can hit the show examples like a couple
of times to get an
impression of what's happening there but
at the moment i do think like hey this
is all about like restaurants and food
so let's just say this is about
like food uh i think that's a good label
for like all the points that i have
there
so that's 55 data points that's nice uh
let's maybe
uh pick up that view and move that down
here and see what is over there
okay that's all about age all right fair
enough so
uh let's add all of those labels uh
maybe do over here let's have a look
there
show examples okay that's all about
jokes
joke add label now
i did a couple of clusters just now and
i don't really need to see them anymore
so what i can also just do now is just
hit redraw
basically this just draws all the points
that aren't labeled yet
so i can repeat this exercise now let's
just zoom in on this
uh yeah let's do a cluster over here
all right let's just show the examples
again okay this is what
what's the time right that's also a good
cluster over there
let's maybe do this one show examples
okay that's nice to meet
okay so i've got a couple of labels now
that's pretty good but now that i think
of it if i sort of redraw now
i do have a couple of these clusters
that are just a little bit more clumped
together
they're a little bit closer and i might
want to sort of pull them apart again
so what you can do is you can say well
let's not
retrain this whole language embedding
but what we could do is say well
let's keep using the same embeddings we
had here but let's just retrain umap
and that way we might also still be able
to pull apart some of these clusters
to make it more easily sort of bulk
label and that's what this retrain
button does
it takes a little while but after a bit
all the ui elements are back
and we see that like the chart has
reoriented a little bit the clusters
have moved
etc and you know
i could basically repeat the same
exercise oh
draw the shape over here show examples
yeah about the weather what you do see
is if you move over a cluster here i
mean it's not necessarily a guarantee
that things will cluster apart this
nicely in real life
i'm using a training data set here which
is giving a bit of a bias perspective
but in reality one thing that you can
imagine is that you might need to
actually zoom in a bit here
so here like what's the time who is your
boss what company created you this
you can imagine there's a couple of
classes actually sort of hidden in here
so it's not like you can have like a
free lunch like you still probably have
to sort of go in here and
do like deep investigation but as a way
to get started
if i think about it maybe this is a
really good idea
what we're looking for are ways for
people to get to their gold standard
data set as quickly as possible
and given that i have on one end a
pretty cool user interface that can deal
with this part
and on the other end i have this library
full of embeddings that are just ready
to go
pre-trained in whatever back-end you
like
i think we can cover kind of a lot of
ground here so this idea of maybe doing
more bulk labeling as a method of
getting people's
uh you know their bootstrapped together
i mean there is merit to that idea i
think
so this is
my active research area at the moment
and um
the thing with this is just to show you
can
nicely export this you get all of your
labels in a nice data frame
so the thing is i can try this out on a
bunch of data sets and that's pretty
cool it's pretty nice
but what i cannot do is run this in
every language out there and confirm
that this is actually working
for that i kind of need this community
around me to tell me like hey vincent
that trick works well for this language
and this trick works well for another
language
so what my job at raza currently kind of
is i support the research team and
explaining what our algorithms are
but a big other part of my job is to
make sort of these
byproducts like this and to see if this
is useful to like the larger community
out there in order to verify that though
i need
um to speak at meetups and like kindly
ask everyone here
um if this trick works um so if
you want to give this a go like i'll
share the links and everything
all this stuff is open source so you can
just goof around whatever you feel like
but i would love to learn this is
something that helps you get started
with a training data set
in the first place because that's
something i would love to get feedback
on
and that is something that i cannot
benchmark on my own i actually need
community feedback for this
so um that's the main thing i actually
just wanted to say
um in general um
my job really is to make tools available
uh i literally get paid to make tools
such that natural language processing is
easier across the board
particularly for raza of course but i
have plenty of byproducts there
but i cannot benchmark data for you
i need to hear from you so please tell
me what does and what doesn't
work um and in particular the
another reason why i think this area of
more research is interesting
is you know in data science we very
often have this stuff that we optimize
you know that's where we could we do the
grid search where we try the bird thing
and we really
hit the power pedal to sort of uh flow
all the tensors etc
but there's also this area where
um maybe we shouldn't really optimize
too much unless we really understand
what our users care about
it's like a problem that happens in
machine learning a lot where we know
that we're optimizing something but we
aren't necessarily sure if this overlap
here is is that big so on my end
um i would love to i i would love to
optimize more
but i would love it even more if people
can tell me
which tools are more useful than others
and i'll gladly contribute to projects
that help you with that regard
especially if you're doing non-english
nlp
that's it
um i there are two questions
uh as far as i can see in the chat and i
have a question as well
and the first question would be have you
considered i mean you showed only the
two-dimensional representation because
that's the only one that you can really
highlight and
draw yeah you can draw only
two-dimensionally
but is there some type of tool that you
maybe thought about
where you can just first of all switch
through all of the dimensions that you
have in your embedding space
such that you could just basically in
each projection you just
sort of highlight it and if it's just a
different projection and there is no
cluster
to the label that you actually wanted so
there's two
two things there so first thing is um i
kind of showed it with this example
i'll just make that big again but in
this example like um
i have two charts here one is bill
length uh vice
versus build depth and the other chart
is flipper length versus body mass
so technically two charts are four
dimensions so that's already an avenue
that you can kind of do
a thing i would love to have in human
learn but it's like
good grief a whole lot of front-end
stuff i gotta do there is this project
called high plot
um it's from facebook and as these and
the idea behind this is you get these
uh parallel coordinates where you can
sort of
uh everything you see here is like its
own
um dimension and you can make a sub
selection on just one dimension at the
time
and what i would love to be able to do
is have like a word embedding where i
say well let's reduce down the ten
dimensions and still keep most of the
variance
and then say oh like hey there seems to
be like i want to get the high value
here
and i want to get the red and okay this
might be a cluster
give that a label and notice that when i
move this around like the
the table at the bottom here also
updates so i think as far as ui goes i
think
this is something i would love to have
but i really need to do the front-end
bit
and that is going to take like a lot a
lot of work because
this high plot thing is pretty cool but
right now they don't support you
removing the hypot logo and they don't
it's not really an open api either so
that's
the main thing i'm battling with but
that's that's what i would love to take
this uh
labeling thing to next okay cool
so uh a question that was asked in the
uh chat but it was more of a technical
nature
when you go down to the actual
implementation of this last
uh labeling uh exactly yeah exactly
uh i think one of the questions was have
you used pca
is there a clustering example because i
mean i guess the question is geared
towards
to get these nice clusters you first
have to implement some type of idea
um how this cluster will actually
manifest itself right
well so it's the thing is that i would
argue it doesn't depend on
there's a couple of axes there so yes
you can use pca here as well it's just
my experience umap is just
badass it just always kind of works it's
i don't know what the secret sauce is it
just
always kind of works so i'm pretty happy
with your map i wouldn't really change
that
now as far as this language thing goes
here i mean you've got birth you can use
here as well if you've got like
sentences you want to do the more
contextual thing
i'm using the universal sentence encoder
here which works pretty well for english
it's pretty fast
but the thing with the language
embeddings in the end
they are trained on wikipedia-like data
sets so if
you're applying this on let's say
twitter data twitter is going to be
significantly different so then
you know these super apparent clusters
are just not going to be there i think
um but then if that's the case i mean
this is more of a matter of well it
depends on the data that you have
like if you have twitter data that's all
about people complaining
you're basically going to see like one
fat cluster in it but if you have like a
little bit of twitter data that's super
positive and some twitter data that's
super negative
yeah then you're gonna more obviously
get clusters but this is more of a data
thing
than a choice of embedding in my
experience at least
okay uh and another question that was
just posted by
uh somebody from austin texas
uh he asked if there's a github repo
if i mention it again yeah so there's
another repo for this presentation per
se but like everything
i'm showing here is super open source so
if you type what lies rasa
um you'll get to this github repository
it's fully
documented i'm pretty happy with the
layout
if you're interested in the bulk
labeling demo if you type bulk label
ling raza you'll actually find like two
youtube videos that explain the
technique more in depth
and especially this video
like it just has all the links to the
notebooks that you can pretty much copy
and paste
um
so like again everything i'm showing
here is open source and also all the
embeddings that i showed earlier
they're also available in raza so if
you're interested in making a raza
assistant and you're wondering hey do i
have these embeddings um
i'm trying to make them available um if
there's tools missing
let me know on twitter i'd love to hear
so
uh there's actually a question regarding
um weekly supervised
tools like snorkel if there's some type
of
compatibility or if they're if you have
any experience or thoughts
on how this might work in combination
with it yeah so
um so when i made human learn i
i wasn't integrating with snorkel i was
integrating with scikit-learn
and it's my understanding that snorkel
does the same thing like snorkel won't
integrate with my hobby projects that's
fine
snorkel integrates with scikit-learn so
far so good
i will say like i think i have a
slightly different approach though
because
um let's just go to the documentation
page for human learn
to show real quick so
inside of human learn we've also got
these function classifiers so the idea
is you can say hey here's a function
it's like a weak classifier
and you can pass it any python function
the keyword arguments become grid
searchable like that's that's some of
the stuff that we have here
what this library doesn't do though
which i think snorkel does do
like snorkel has this thing of well we
have all these weak supervisors
and then we combine them in a magic way
and then the prediction's better
i've never really understood what the
magic thing is that they exactly do
so that's the one thing that my library
doesn't it's it's
it's just some psychic learning
components really i believe that there
are some clever things that snorkel does
there but
um i'm really really doing like
the stupidly simple thing here that's
the what i'm trying to go for
okay i think uh there aren't any more
questions in the chat
so um that will be it from you
does anyone else have any questions
i have one person asking me for uh if we
have limburg
limburg's uh word embeddings um
i and the thing i think we do have them
uh
i also think we have fish to be honest i
think there's a couple of dialects in
here
lim bergen i think that's that one yep
it should be said though like there's
definitely like a lot of things in here
but i think it's also still safe to say
it's fairly european centric this this
particular library
because everything that this library
does is trained on wikipedia so if your
language doesn't have like a
reasonably big wikipedia section then
there's no embeddings trained for you so
i don't want to suggest that this is
like a
you know homogeneously distributed
language embedding package
looking at the world but there's
definitely a lot in here which is kind
of nice
the only thing i do want to maybe
mention is that wikipedia data isn't
perfect i don't know if people heard
what happened with scottish gaelic
the story here was i believe it was like
an american 16 year old
um who basically thought oh you know
it'd be funny if i just upload like
wikipedia articles with words that sound
scottish and no one really checked that
and apparently like
a big chunk of the the the scottish
wikipedia
i believe was uploaded by a 16 year old
and therefore all the word embeddings
that were trained on that
uh can't be super relied upon which is
probably happening with this
uh embedding as well
uh but uh irish gaelic is also an
interesting one someone just asked
yeah so irish i guess is in here it's
also pretty cool if you go to the
documentation of this project by the way
you can
um you can basically say the vocabulary
size and how many dimensions
and then you can just get the bokeh
visualization so you can also just
zoom in and get like an impression of
all the words that are in here
on the subway so that's also something
that you can do on your own time if
you're interested in exploring this
further
so two
there's a couple of questions about how
you export the data but
it's indeed just the pandas data frame
uh that's it so you can save it in
whatever format you like
if you scroll to the bottom uh here
you'll notice the uh that i end up with
this uh
data frame basically i'm interested in
maybe turning this into a package
it's just that i would prefer to have a
little bit more feedback from the
community before i do something
more formal with it
great what's the best way to communicate
with you
by issues on some type of github or
on some type of github i also have a
good lab account but i think it would be
better if people post issues on the
right repo
um now so uh if you go to twitter
uh if you find the guy in the ball pit
that's me
uh so if you type vincent pie data
you'll probably find me but uh
fishnets88 is my alias um if you look
for
raza or like vincent raza on linkedin
you'll also find me
um if it's related to my projects i
certainly do prefer github but if you
talk to me on linkedin i will talk back
talk to me twitter i will talk back
any feedback is appreciated
thank you very much no we don't
oh okay
just see there was a last question how
can you add in the bokeh app we
via text input in new text and enter it
in the label that already exists
it's it's all happening inside of a
jupiter notebook so no one is telling
you not to do things
uh you will might maybe need to code it
up yourself don't you want to add that
feature
but if you could do it with python code
you can do it inside of jupyter notebook
so it
should be possible
[Music]
okay uh so yeah thank you very much
thank you very interesting yeah
uh so now the second presentation
uh will be by uh actually jean
uh myself uh of uh some of the work with
get your guide uh so let me
start setting things up you do you want
to take a break or you want to
to start it right away
or i will i will just
let me setting up and like we can just
have like a five minute chats
um yeah like
so people let's say we continue
at uh ten to eight
okay so we have like five minute breaks
between the action
so you can grab a coffee grab a tea
say hi to the cat
[Music]
mm-hmm
and also to want to say so for the ones
who are here uh we'll also have
try to have um a more
meetup field uh after the second
presentation where we'll go to wonder
so wonder is a
nice platform that we use
once once in our company and it looks
very promising
but basically you are kind of in a 2d
map where
when you have a point and when you move
around and meet other people you will
start to be able to interact with them
and so we'll share the link at the end
and maybe we can have some
more informal conversation when if you
want to ask questions to some people or
maybe just
create group so basically to to try to
have more this um
informal knowledge sharing and exchange
between members
let's see the first try with this
platform so please
share feedback with us afterwards i'll
be very interested to see
afterwards or we can find it tomorrow
i will share it in the in the chat and i
will also
also post it in the pi data
page on beta
theo yeah do you have a special name for
your machine learning platform
uh good question damn
machine learning puns machine learning
puns quick someone
we we are open to suggestions so please
definitely do not hesitate to
ah
florence and the machine learning i
don't know yeah
[Laughter]
yeah sometimes
sometimes people have their own name for
their platforms you know like davis
ai or so yeah you can have
t-j-i-e-i
when i was younger i think it'd be kind
of funny to have like a company named
intelligence inc
and then the title under it would be we
make sense um but then this whole hype
thing started and i kind of went down
it's a really bad idea let's don't even
go there
i think it's actually a company name i
guess it probably is
that wouldn't surprise me too much
intelligence
page rank has a very special meaning can
you guess
um i'll gladly hear any recommendations
you might have
larry page i don't know exactly
that was the homer right i heard
maybe you can do that
what does the what does the requentus
say to the bayesian
okay we tried again what does the for
quentin say to the basin
you're average what does the bayesian
say to the finitis
you're mean okay
it's
[Music]
okay it's ten to eight so
i propose to start
welcome for the second part
um so jean jean and i will be
presenting the foundation of our ml
platform
get your guide so my name is theodore
and i'm french working at get your guide
since
august 2021 as a data scientist
in the recommendation and relevance team
hey everybody uh my name is jim carlo
machado i'm from brazil
i'm in europe now for three years
working at gettro guide
and there as an engineer facing
[Music]
solving problems around recommendations
search and ranking basically
so in the next 25 minutes i will present
how we lay the
foundation of our ml platform at get
your guide
so to make to make it easier for our
data scientists to
iterate through the cycle of first id
then coding then experiment
so if you have any questions please
write it down in the chat
and we'll answer them at the end
okay great so this is our agenda for
this presentation
so first jean will start with an
introduction about get your guide
then we will dive into the use cases
that we have in data science in our
company
and jean will also present how we
iterated
on the deployment of our models and
their limitations
next we will have uh represent the
foundation of our platform uh in the
first part we will explain how we lever
how we leverage mfl
ml flow sorry to manage our models and
then
in second part john will explain how we
use the templating to bootstrap our
project
with the good practices and we'll
conclude with some final words and open
for questions
yes so to talk about our machine
learning platform
in get your guide first we have to uh
introduce catcher guide i guess
for european ideals like this uh
you probably know uh the company but in
case you don't know
so get your guide is building one of the
biggest marketplaces for travel
experiences
uh we are connecting millions of
customers over
our catalog of more than 40 000
experiences worldwide
to summarize our mission is to give
access to the world for incredible
experiences and
to get more concrete about what that
means is uh so if you want for instance
to skydive
on the sugarloaf in rio or
you want to see the sunset of new york
city
from the top of the empire state
building
or explore food markets on hong kong
hecho guide is a place to uh
to find this kind of activities and it's
just some few clicks away
of you as you might guess the travel
sector was pretty much hit
by the pandemic uh
so we took this time as our opportunity
to uh
invest heavily on our tag foundations
um yeah to be ready for the market
rebound
uh and the machine learning platform is
part of this investment
so back to me so now that you have a
kind of
an idea of what the company is doing i
will tell you more about
how we are using ml at get your guide so
actually our data sense team
started five years ago and uh
and during this time until today the
amount of projects
that we own grew and so we use machine
learning
in different areas so for example we
use them to uh to rank the activities we
propose to
uh to show on the top the most relevant
from our inventory and we show them on
the different landing pages on also the
search result
result pages and see you can have an
example here
you can also just go get your guide and
we'll find
also our the the
website we also use machine learning to
recommend personalized activities to
our customers with panels that we
distribute also
on the on the website and on the app
we also uh use machine learning to help
the tourists to discover a destination
and that's the best activities on get
your guide
with paid search uh the most famous
one with google
also we also use ml for domain
forecasting
to predict uh uh
to try to predict what will be the
demands of our pre-buy tickets
and also simply for planning we also use
ml for
automatically labeling our inventory of
activities
so in total we have currently more than
20 projects that we need to
currently maintain and which is
distributed
among two teams and we also have uh some
models that
uh are in other teams and we also need
to
some from time to time uh maintain
and so as you can see we start to reach
our critical size
and uh so for that to try to stay
aligned between the different teams
and the different uh uh project
we agree on a set of principles that we
all follow
and we cannot split them in kind of six
pillars
so the first one will be about the
strategy so how do we prioritize the
work
and so for example we favor business
value of a state-of-the-art models
the workflow how do we plan our work so
we
uh we incorporate the data to informal
planning
uh dynamically the third one will be
about the model
how we build our model so we value small
iteration of existing model
and finally also the performance is only
proven online with a b test
which is very important for us uh
then the first one is about qa how do we
assure the quality of model so
if we are building we we want to build
solid and resilient deployment
then we have the injury in principle uh
how do we build basically how do we
build our infrastructure and we want to
make sure that our work is reproducible
and also modular and finally the
stakeholder engagement
how do we engage with our partner and we
want to promote
and educate our partners across the
company about the data product mindset
so in a retrospective uh we showed that
for two of those uh oh
sorry yeah two uh
for two of this dimension especially uh
the so the qa
and the injuring we uh we're not at
standard
um so if you are building a model maybe
just for
research and you are the only one using
it uh it might not be a
big deal if you have a broken model or
for
some days but for us it's quite critical
because if one of our mobile is down
then it will affect the website and
ultimately our customers
and that means we are losing potential
revenue and
this can go really quick fast so in the
magnitude of thousands of euros for
every hours our model
are done so we uh
agree that we need to improve this
dimension and this is what this
uh platform is about
so now jean will explain a bit more
about the different approach that we
have to develop and deploy our models
so as you said we've been doing machine
learning for
around now five years and uh until
2019 around we've been using this
approach
of notebooks first uh and to
go to production and basically notebooks
are great we
indispensable for us they are widely
used by
ml practitioners they have a very
low intra point for
people you don't have to install a
system in your machine to start doing
machine learning you can just open a tab
in your browser
they are great to start new projects
prototype ideas
and also they have amazing visualization
for you know
tech people so they are great and
very necessary for doing data science
but uh they
have also some features that are not
very suitable for going to production
for instance you can
most notebook solutions you don't have a
proper version control it's also not the
best platform
to do reuse um
and also it's not at the right place to
do tests you don't have
uh uh yeah the infrastructure in place
to do that
notebooks then uh are very easy to break
in summary uh
what if you are going to production with
a notebook running
your system and you open that notebook
and accidentally type something i'm very
good at typing
stuff wrong in notebook cells and that's
very easy to break your
your system uh and in our case breaker
systems
really means like stop ranking relevant
products for
when the user searches or not or showing
noise in our recommendations
or even like paying a lot of money to
google to better the wrong that
so there's clear side effects that uh
for us
are uh not uh make it a not
good decision to go in that direction so
and also they are so they actually go
into production with notebooks is not
aligned with our principles we cannot
also build
increments of code and maintained for a
long term like with
uh teams maintaining it rather than
individuals as skill sets if you are
just one person
working on our research the constraints
are very different
so to be truthful to our principles we
saw that we needed
an improvement next slide
so the second approach we took
towards improving this system was
this was made like from 2019 2020
we ported our code to github
and uh that then removing the
[Music]
uh the necessity to run notebooks in
production
the the workflow looks more or less like
this you
have some working piece of code in a
notebook then import it to a library
but still then there is a question on
how you deploy it and we opted for the c
plus that first to be incremental
so um we build it as a python library
and basically do a manual deploy to a s3
bucket that can run stand in our
in production infrastructure um
yes but this approach also has its
limitations
uh when you start from a github entity
project
you have like uh zero uh out of the box
automation for your quality the quality
aspects of your project
uh and um that makes also
means that the different projects will
have different ways of
uh automating and they will look very
different people will find different
diversion solutions as
hard to avoid people in such a different
set of engineering practices
so given that everything also starts
from the zero ground
we most of the solutions ended up doing
manual deployment and also a
new deployment for the bucket uh
you can see how that can breaks where it
can break very fast
uh just by doing enough times manual
deployment
you gonna break it eventually uh and uh
was not only once that happened we
were building a testing model and uh
somehow
wrote in the production uh location
so you broke the system this way
um yeah that's two dimensions or
problems with this approach the third is
that we don't have
actually tracking we are also of our
parameters we are in the dark
for in the to know uh which parameters
uh the data scientists use to tune the
model
all the learnings that happen uh that
led to the model to be
what it is you if you don't have that
track it
peop other people joining your project
might have to relearn these things and
uh yeah that just makes it much more
expensive and hard to collaborate
so all these uh problems led us to
to the need of thing uh to the
conclusion that we need to think on
machine learning more realistically in
our
thus uh the need of a machine learning
platform
next yeah and so now i will present
uh more about the platform and so what
we built so far
uh so we'll break it down in two in two
parts so first i will talk a bit more
about
how we make sure that uh uh
that we are making machine learning
reproducible
and so for that um we can say that
actually if in machine learning if you
just have the code
usually you cannot go that far you can
it's bad
but if you have the code and the data
it's already better
because at least you can try to
reproduce but
what you expect is have the code the
data
and also the executables so with that
you are kind of
understand uh what are the libraries
that are needed the version
of them and so this is a good way to
make it possible finally
what you what you should have as a gold
standard and what which will aim for is
to have the code
the data the executable uh and also the
logs
uh so with that you are able to iterate
faster because
if something is broken between two
iteration uh then you just need to
compile the
compare the the the the version
uh between the two to be able to fix it
quickly uh the end of the
uh faster also because you have
everything that you need
to understand what happened previously
and also
if you want uh for the scientific method
approach
this is the right way to improve our
model to be able to reproduce each steps
that led to this point and so
uh to help us with that uh we are use we
use
uh a new tool and would like to
introduce you to
mlflow so we leverage ml flow uh
which is an open source software and
the goal of this software project is to
have a kind of platform not limited to a
few framework
uh or also company infrastructure and
these tools is really useful for us in
uh in two areas so first it allows to
log the metrics the parameter
and also the output parameter output
model that
we train and this is with the tracking
module from mlphil and also
we are able to see the different uh we
can have an overview of all the model
that we are currently using in
production
and so for that they have the model
registry uh
concepts with ml flow and so with this
we are able to make it reproducible
because we
with that we have the code version that
we that we are using for that training
because uh with the git hash we can log
them in mr flow
we have the data that we that we store
and we log the path to make sure that we
know where it's coming from
we have the executable which is the
docker image that we also
uh is but it's logged within our flow
and finally we have all the logs that
are
linked to the mr flow and uh also
pushed uh to a nice ui
and i will show you how it looks like on
the on the ui so
for the tracking so all the experiments
this is an example
of an experiment so a set of runs that
we have
that you can have and so here you have
in one dashboard uh all the runs that
you did
and you can see the different parameters
that were used the different metrics
and you can also order them by
parameters filters
etc and you see uh when it was started
what who was the user etc etc
uh so and the second one is about the ml
flow model registry
so this is a dashboard where we see all
the model that we have in production
and also you have a stage for each of
them so we know if they are in staging
production or archived
and uh by also digging into that we can
see
like the different version from when to
when they were in which stage
uh who changed them from stages and
also go back to the tool to the training
and
see that the metric that will use the
parameters
and the logs
okay and just to give you a small
example like
how it looks in the code uh it's
actually fairly simple
so you just import mlflow and then you
can just
let me put the pointer uh you just with
an offload
run and if you want to log the
parameters you just
log a parameter if you want to log the
metrics etc and once you have a model
that you
have that you want to fit then you can
log the model by
saying with a model uh when you want to
have it
saved and if you want to register model
to have it in the model history you just
say how you want to have it there so a
very
very interesting tool
so we'll talk now about the second part
of the puzzle so we see
reproducibility as key for a platform uh
but
to have it and also being able to
deploy to production reliably we have to
increase the amount of automation we
have on our systems
and a concept that summarizes this
automation concern is
mlops which was originally
derived as a derivation of devops which
were a
practice of summarizes machine learning
operations
uh more specific to machine learning
rather than
uh devops and uh
but a central tenet of this ops movement
is that every change we make in our code
base
uh in the master branch is ready to go
to production it's like a production
valid
change uh that improved a lot
the software engineering practices and
we believe that it can improve also our
machine learning practices
so uh not only every change
should be able to go to production it
should
go to production automatically which uh
requires and to do that it requires some
automation in place
uh not to start from zero with the
github repository
uh to solve that problem we came up with
a solution of a template
that i will explain you next
so in get your guide we have internal
tooling that is used to
uh speed up the development process
like if you want to set up a service or
someone you can use this
tool and uh it's basically
contains uh a templating on steroids
functionality which allowed us to create
our own
machine learning service template
and these templates then it does it sets
up a skeleton for our
machine learning uh project but uh also
creates the github repository
creates the aws infrastructure necessary
to run
this model and integrates with
ml flow and it also
adds ci cd so
[Music]
cicd is basically the practice
that allows us to go to production
automatically
while making our systems making sure
that our systems are working i will
explain you them in the next slide
it's in details
so uh that's
every change we do in our uh
github repo that contains a model
will then pass using our ccd pipeline it
will pass
through a series of checks and if all
these checks are
uh positive they will end up in
production basically so
our first series of checks are units
tests we set
up some by default but uh the data
scientist then
uh as is desirable that he continues
building new tests
and uh we do also uh
style checks type system checks with my
pi
and security checks to see for instance
if you are using uh outstate version of
a dependency
and once all of those checks are done we
trigger automatic training
that if also succeeds we then
do automatic deployment uh
in the next step we have a visualization
of this process
so all starts with a notebook the data
scientists
do the exploration and we reach a point
where we say hey this goes
this is a serious project let's leave it
move it to production so at that point
the data scientist basically bootstraps
a new service
it creates all the infrastructure and at
every change
we trigger automatic deploy that
if succeeds uh trains uh our model and
saves it
into ml flow and from ml flow then we
are ready to distribute
to many other sources and what flow
makes it uh
is the the ml flow registry is the place
where our model resides and can go to
production
also some to conclude
uh so as we grew uh
our data sentence we need to refine our
our process and uh to make it more
sophisticated
so to do that we integrated good soft
uh good software engineering practices
and we also
added some twists to be able to adapt to
machine learning
uh especially with mrflow and this
automatic training
and with that we can help our data
scientists to
first build faster by focusing on the
model
and the data and not on the
infrastructure
and setting things up so instead of
needed one or two a few days to be able
to
uh to start a new project then in 10
minutes your
you have it ready and set up we
are we're able to deploy safer with
automated test
and the ci every time and also we have
auto automatic documentation
of the experiments that we are doing
thanks to mlflow
and regarding the next steps for the
platform uh right now the teams are in
the process of supporting
the projects we have to the template uh
and at the same time we are looking into
real-time predictions and
that's that's a feature desirable for
real-time personalization so we wanted
to really react
for the latest interactions of the
customers in the website
and the platform is just uh yet the
right place to uh iterate on that
concept
we are also uh we already foresee the
need of a feature star so
uh as our mo we add more and more models
we wanted to reuse the features
that they are composed of and uh so we
need a place to
set them all and be able to retrieve
them
and uh yeah we are continuously looking
into monitoring in our systems
uh it's very easy for the models
to drift in production and uh yeah
that's
something we will be continuously
investing on
uh yeah the last slide uh
this basically completes our
presentation uh if this kind of work
also
sounds interesting to you uh you
must not i we are hiring and uh the link
is just in this slide you can
access it and now we are open to go
through
the questions
um okay thank you very much so
one of the questions that was asked by
mata linen
was are you running ammo flow on data
bricks
with a smiley face yeah and then so
yeah do you want to say something yeah i
just wanted to say maybe
for the people who do not know
databricks is kind of a
data platform provider and which also
provide
a way to have a centralized notebook
which run on cluster and be able to
use spark and
and also they also propose a
management rule
a small remark by updo
would be nice to have a whole workflow
summary
uh from hypothesis idea to fully
automated
reproduction um is that a possibility or
actually yeah we have uh
uh we wrote a blog post uh which we
should go live
in the next uh month so
and we will go through exactly this
whole process
of uh going from hypothesis to id and
then
uh going to production with that yeah
that's true that's your question
um another question by uh dimitrov
i'm not exactly sure what he's referring
to but why have you made your own
there are aws sagemaker and azure ml
i mean you know
yeah we are picking the pieces from many
open source projects
uh and actually uh
we have to already uh take into account
our legacy or the way that we do things
databricks is at
the core of our operations so and also
it's just a natural
uh follow-up from that and we still can
leverage sagemaker to go to production
that's actually one of the tools for
our real-time inference that we are
analyzing but
uh yeah so we are for sure not
inventing everything at home okay so we
yeah sure yeah we do not try to reinvent
the wheel and
actually we are not building our own we
are not assembling our own
so we are taking the parts of the
different things so
so another question by abdul um what do
you mean by automatic training
automl or why not use some ml
ops framework but then you just
basically mentioned i think
your ml ops right
um i think the question um basically
answered itself
or do you want to comment on this
we are not using automl but what we made
by automatic training
is when you have uh
when you push something into the github
repository it will automatically
run the test and if the test path and
you are also pushing to master so we
don't want to
so when we want to have a new basically
model
by pushing a new feature to master then
it will automatically
that fundamental automatically will
start trigger a training
on the whole data set so
a very elaborate chrome job
um so another question um
are you using something like cookie
cutter uh for
templating probably that wouldn't be
enough
for the thing you achieved yeah
uh so cookie cutter is a really good
example uh so we are not using cookie
gutter we are using ginger
uh behind the scene which is kind of the
same the same
uh thing but uh
why we have what we have with kick that
actually is
uh more than that because it's also
basically already setting up the
infrastructure so we are connecting with
them flow we are connecting with the
data bricks we have the
secrets managed we create the ecr so all
this thing
is already pushed together directly
so you don't have to do this you just
have to run kick that foot strap
so yes exactly cookie cutter will not be
enough
so uh i don't see any more questions and
i don't have any questions either um
and i didn't see any questions on
youtube youtube was
sort of quiet this time oh there is
another
uh question can you speak a bit
about any challenges you have faced with
understanding
utilization of the deployed models and
how
you've addressed them another do
do you understand what is meant
i think the challenges in understanding
utilization of deployment right
so not sure i'm not sure either can you
can you refresh brent
um yeah oh
[Music]
yes well one thing to
say is one big challenge is to have the
right
data in place so
[Music]
we are also like at this point uh
putting uh on hold all or uh
iterations on some specific models of
recommendations because we
still don't have the data to see if our
changes
are uh being uh affecting our
our pipeline in uh correct way so uh
the teams and the teams that own the the
these events and sending this data
around
are distributed so there are many social
challenges around
uh just uh monitoring your
your model and see if that's working in
the right direction i'm not sure if that
exactly answer your question
maybe you have another take on it here
yeah i should so if you've seen zombie
model uh accumulating over time
uh so actually we have the we
we have like quite event driven so we
know the number of requests that
have been sent and so each time we have
a new request that we know
we are able to to measure how
requested our server our models are
so they are not getting zombies uh
definitely they are
heavily used but
what is sometimes challenging is
moving from one model to the next with a
new api or thing like that because
getting all the consumer of our models
to
adapt to the new model which might need
new parameters i think that that
is what is uh challenging because each
team have its own priorities and things
like that
but that's uh yeah
it's not specific to ml any kind of uh
micro service architecture
kind of have these challenges i believe
okay there are a bunch of new questions
uh
do you see them yeah uh so after
what framework monitoring do you use for
a b testing
uh so not us
but uh get your guy build its own
framework for a b testing where we are
basically able to
flip the coins uh to be able to test
new features and it's used heavily by uh
by a lot of teams actually from design
to
machine learning uh to also back ends
um and for the monitoring uh
maybe jean you can answer that better
i wasn't sure if it's monitoring for ap
testing specific or monitoring general
but our two for
keeper team are yeah keep an eye on our
systems
is data talk the main one there's a lot
of
there's other tools like for monitoring
or however events behave
but as a dog is the more the biggest one
[Music]
and question from is there any concept
of ownership of particle uh
sorry it's a concept of ownership of
particular models
uh in your platform extending on create
uh so yes the model are owned by teams
basically and they are responsible to
to keep them running and keep them
healthy basically
um and their mission teams like for
instance our team is
recommendations and relevance as another
team
taking care of our
ads and so they're kind of clustered
around domains and
the team owned them basically
any other questions
[Music]
okay
thank you brunch i will stop sharing
and i will stop
recording
and so now what i propose is to try
this uh wanda so this uh thing that i
talked during the
interview so you should maybe also stop
youtube
yeah well i just want to say to youtube
so if you want to join
uh the wonder you can also by going to
uh meetup pi data berlin looking
in the comments of the february meetings
and you will be able to find the link to
wonder and
hope to see you there